dans un instant c'est l'association art
magique qui nous présentera son enquête
policière double face c'est le nom de sa
nouvelle création une comédie musicale
aimait déjà retour sur le salon du livre
à saint cyr l'école avec ce sujet de
julie rocha soirée celle d'elodie moines
samedi 2e édition du salon du livre de
saint cyr l'école dans un lieu
emblématique le lycée militaire avec une
programmation tournée vers les
personnages historiques qui ont
participé à son rayonnement comme madame
de maintenon napoléon bonaparte et le
général charles de gaulle pour parler du
général de gaulle mais surtout de la
dimension spirituelle qui était tout à
fait intégrés qui imprégnait sa personne
sa pensée son action depuis le plus
jeune âge jusqu'à sa mort d'autres
auteurs locaux ou même des dom-tom
étaient conviés à ce salon pour échanger
avec leurs lecteurs les lecteurs me
disent souvent en fait qu' ils ont
démarré mais roman et qu'ils n'ont pas
pu les arrêter jusqu'à la fin on me
reproche parfois quelques nuits blanches
et j'en suis très fier
l'occasion aussi de visiter un
établissement rarement ouverts au grand
public je vais me promener un petit peu
dans pour découvrir le merveilleux
patrimoine
saint cyrien y en a aussi profité pour
visiter l'école de saint cyr je suis
surpris qui a agréablement surpris du
décor et
ses magnifiques comme un homme écoles
d'ores et déjà la ville pense à la
troisième édition de son salon du livre
il pourrait s'ouvrir l'an prochain aux
écoliers collégiens et lycéens
est toujours question de culture dans ce
set 8 avec lucie était là et solitaire
bonsoir à tous les deux vous êtes des
représentants de l'association arts
magiques et le 8 juin à
montigny-le-bretonneux la ferme du manet
vous allez présenter double face c'est
une enquête policière mise en musique et
justement l'histoire de double face
comédie musicale qui prend forme autour
d'un fait divers une jeune femme que
l'on retrouve morte à paris et ensuite
et ensuite c'est un fait divers qui sont
de la première vue banale mais qui nous
emmène finalement au coeur d'une
tragédie humaine où différents
sentiments différents
milieux et différentes situations
totalement opposées les unes aux autres
se retrouvent pour pour donner la vie et
puis la mort parce que dans le résumé
qui ont eu la plupart des personnes
c'est que cette jeune femme venait
d'accoucher autour de cette naissance
est au tour de de sept morts il y a il y
a des histoires beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus profonde et voilà vous êtes chargé
de la mise en scène de l'écriture
réalisations sont les lycées charge est
plutôt de la musique il ya des codes
dans le polar est ce que vous avez cassé
ses codes déjà sur l'écriture et puis
ensuite on s'intéressera à la musique
j'ai envie de dire presque totalement
sur l'écriture je ne sais pas si je
casse j'ai de toute façon mon style et
je ne respecte pas forcément les codes
je fais comme comme bon me semble
ensuite la il faut savoir qu'on ne
s'agit pas d'un livre à lire ou d'un
film qu'on regarde c'est vraiment une
mise en scène théâtrale et musicale
d'impôt narre donc je ne sais pas si ça
existe déjà je n'en ai pas encore vus on
a appelé nous polar musical je ne sais
pas s'il y en a déjà deux faits mais en
tout cas c'était quelque chose pour nous
de nous vaud avec aucun repère dans ce
style de comédie musicale donc pas
forcément de code a brimé par des codes
déjà enfermé dans des cases donc je
serai à l'écriture pour la musique cette
fois ci de lecture de musique dans tout
à fait c'est une création du début à la
fin et la musique va être construite
autour du scénario qui a écrit que l'uci
a écrit et chaque scène va être décrite
en musique
par le biais de
de différents acteurs qui rompt un rôle
de comédien et de chanteurs voir
danseurs pendant la pièce vous allez
travailler justement vous avez écrit
d'abord les morceaux travailler ensuite
sur l'écriture du scénario inverse le
scénario est écrit en premier par l'uci
et puis ensuite à moi d'adapter la
musique de créer deux pour reproduire
les climats qui vont en fonction des
scènes et aussi en fonction des gens que
l'on rencontre et qui viennent partager
l'aventuré avec nous donc les comédiens
qui sont aussi en co écriture sur
certains morceaux
aussi bien musical que
que textuel parce que les comédiens à ce
sont des membres de l'association art
magique puisque c'est votre association
qui crée le spectacle de a à z sont
professionnels amateurs on va dire
semi-pro certains sont plus ou moins
membres de l'association art magique
parce qu'on travaille avec eux depuis
longtemps sur les différents spectacles
qui ont été créés aussi bien sûr la
première comédie où est passée la lune
sur de cabaret la sueur double de face
sur le groupe de musique d'art magique
qui s'appelle alpha project donc il ya
des personnes qui sont déjà des
professionnels de la musique qui
travaillent avec nous ensuite ces
professionnels de la musique sont soumis
à un nouvel exercice pour certains qui
est la comédie donc notre je parle
notamment de michel que vous avez dû
recevoir lors de l'une de vos émissions
je parle de jean paul qui est batteur en
fait t'es qui là se retrouve dans le
rôle de comédien une autre rencontre que
nous avons fait avec une personne
s'appelle blandine bohème qui voilà qui
a un autre travail mais qui se retrouve
un qui a déjà fait de la comédie
musicale qui remonte à nouveau sur les
planches et puis sinon d'autres qui ont
des voiles à des occupations qui n'ont
rien à voir avec la comédie mais qu'il a
fallu former mais ça veut dire que vous
prenez beaucoup de risques parce que
entre deux les codes qu'il a fallu
réinventer entre les comédiens que vous
mettez sur scène vous êtes serein
présentation sa mère est encore à
l'étude au fait si nous sommes stressés
ça ne vient pas du fait de la nouveauté
et du risque pris en fait parce que
justement ce risque et le fait de casser
tous les codes donne une liberté totale
donc notre stress viendrait j'ai pas
d'un manque de sommeil d'un manque de
temps mais là tout est prêt en tout cas
pour le spectacle vous en êtes où
dernière la pétition peaufinage
peaufinage petit réglage des derniers
instants
je pense que ça va aller vous aimez
justement malgré tout prendre un petit
peu des risques parce que vous êtes
lancés dans cette aventure de comédie
musicale depuis depuis trois ans vous
l'avez mentionné tout à l'heure il ya eu
un compte y avait un cabaret l'année
dernière à la c'est un polar chaque
année ce sera sur une thématique
différente vous avez déjà en tête des
choses que vous aimeriez faire
selon d'inspiration en fait ça tient à
peu de chose c'est être en train de
marcher dans la rue et puis on entend un
mot en ce qui me concerne c'est comme ça
que ça marche un mot peut déclencher un
spectacle pour soheil au niveau de la
musique il va le dire mais même moi j'ai
besoin d'eux j'ai besoin de créer ces
mondiaux mon
mât nécessité vitale donc j'ai besoin de
créer puis là j'ai la possibilité avec
lui si la ville de montigny de pouvoir
en faire profiter tout le monde de mes
créations donc effectivement j'ai
toujours toujours en tête des choses que
j'ai envie de faire ce spectacle de
polars en redonne la date le 8 juin 20h
à la ferme du manet à montigny 18 euros
plein tarif pour les adultes 12 pour les
enfants ce qu'il y aura des tarifs
vraiment comment on peut nous appeler il
ya un numéro de téléphone il ya des
renseignements qui se sont affichés à
l'écran est ce qu'il y aura d'autres
représentations en dehors de cette date
unique est ce que le spectacle va lui
arrive encore après c'est notre souhait
en tout cas ce qu'il est prévu ces deux
enfin en ce qui me concerne je ne parle
pas pour sauver elle qui a déjà la tête
qui plein d'idées et je l'accompagnerai
de toute façon mais en fait l'idée c'est
de avant de se lancer dans une nouvelle
création essayer de faire vivre celle
qui existe et il s'avère que pour celle
là je ne vais pas trop en dire mais nous
avons déjà de la demande pour que ce
soit à nouveau jouer après dans d'autres
accords et dalmat dumas n'est pas faux
aura l'occasion de le relayer sur ce
plateau merci à tous les deux donc cette
pièce que vous n'oubliez pas à les
découvrir à montigny le bretonneux merci
à vous